Hello Freak bitches that again.
I mean fuck starches pain now is fucking
a is killer.
I mean music is so hard to pin down.
It's funny too because you know,
we had a bit of it.
We had a fallen out recently and you
couldn't find a bigger storage will
faint to me.
I just listened to his record on the way
over here and it's a fucking
masterpiece,
but he also wants to talk to me right
now.
What happened?
Well,
here's the thing I don't even mind
talking about,
right?
I in an interview,
I said that he was,
but I just honestly,
what I believe,
I think he is.
You're going to laugh when I say it,
but I swear this is what I fucking
believe.
I think he's a Patriot ass.
I'll just let that sink in for a second.
I think he's taken motherfuckers out and
I confronted him about it.
Where did you get this information?
Well,
let me tell you video.
See,
I'm like I said I knew him back in
Kentucky and he goes,
this fucker goes to the navy.
Right,
right.
That's magic.
Magic magic.
He's,
he's worked for the governor.
Imagine being in the navy and you look
next to you and some guy just picked up
a guitar and start singing and it starts
with Simpson.
Imagine that there's no fucking way,
like the greatest singer guitarist,
one of the best ones in the world right
now.
Would you agree with that?
Oh,
for sure.
He's just sitting next to you on a
fucking boat and they decides,
you know what?
I want to leave the navy when he was
young.
But I'm saying you can't just quit the
navy.
Uh,
what you do term,
you know,
he didn't do his term.
He fucking left.
Brilliant.
So He owes the gum.
How long did he go?
I don't know the fuck.
Listen.
All my facts aren't together,
but he leaves.
Can you do that?
I thought that's like you go awol and
they didn't go a while.
He's fucked.
So why I'm thinking,
why is he fucking out?
Oh,
well you should talk to Alex Jones about
this.
Well,
no,
but I'm telling you I don't need to talk
to him.
I got the answers.
He leaves.
Right?
Right now I he,
all of a sudden out of nowhere,
he just puts out the fucking wreck.
So what if you're in the government,
you want to take some fuckers out,
put their dick in the dirt,
luck.
I'm saying take those motherfuckers
down.
What's the best way to do it and this
done.
But men have been done before by some,
some other Hollywood stars.
Tension music artist alive.
And you as you.
Well Nigga as a front,
but who travels the most efficient music
artists?
Yeah,
and you gotTa have them legit cause he's
got to go fucking play right?
Checkout circles to it.
Now,
here's what I'm going to say right now.
I know you're laughing at me.
I said you both laughed at him,
but this motherfucker has toured Europe.
Fucking tent.
He's,
he's toured England.
10 Times you ever heard of who's your
favorite country music artists from
England?
They don't listen to fucking country
music.
They listened to it.
You don't play and listen to it.
He's going over there fucking killing
people and.
But this fucker,
it's gone to how many times you eat a
lot.
Yeah.
You ever met a Japanese guy and you go,
who's your favorite country artist?
They don't go,
you know,
they don't go,
ah,
fuck,
do I can tell you you'll come.
They don't listen to that shit.
He's over there taking motherfuckers
out.
You go down his tour list and you check
the,
check it with the papers of enemies of
the state who been taken out.
That shit fucking lines up,
does it?
I think if I wasn't the specifics,
I can't.
Anyway,
I got a little stone and I thought this
was what happened and I should have
asked him about it,
which is true.
But so he just started accusing them of
being a CIA has done to his face.
I did it on a couple of radio shows and
then.
And this is probably going to break it
open a little bit,
but anyway,
now he's,
he won't.
Why will he confront me about it?
Because it's true.
Right?
And why is this new album all about him?
You heard the record.
It just him talking to his son because
he's seeing shit at night.
He,
he seen the shit,
you know,
why do you write an album about this
serious about jill as like a serious
talk to your child because you've seen
should go down.
You've seen motherfuckers tell you he
loves his kid and no one does that.
No,
that's not a reason to make a record.
He says he's telling his kids,
warning him,
don't do what I did,
you know,
and he's a hired government assassin and
I'm almost positive about this it.
But I'm also getting the truth out
there.
What don't you worry he's going to take
you out for exposing them.
That's what I'm talking about it because
now they know if he takes me out,
we'll know,
we'll then my story will be true.
That's what that guy thought in Russia.
Remember that dude in Russia that was
talking shit about,
uh,
about Putin.
He was a,
like a political rival.
The Putin that he thought because he was
so public,
they'd never take them out.
They shot him with his girlfriend while
he was with his girlfriend.
They shot him in front of a government
building.
That doesn't help my fucking anxiety for
the story.
They'll just get you,
dude.
Especially if you go to Russia,
don't tour Russia.
I don't know.
Well,
I mean,
again,
I,
I'm,
my facts aren't like 100 percent
together,
but from what I've seen that,
why wouldn't he talk to me about it?
Then you say,
well,
you know,
people get tested when you call them
killers.
They get,
um,
you know,
they feel bad.
I don't know,
man.
Yeah,
you asked me.
I mean,
whatever.
I think I'm onto something,
but whatever.
Anyway.